welcome to the David Pakman show I am of
course not David Pakman I am Benjamin
Dixon host of the Benjamin Dixon show
and also host of like it or not on
content news which are the studios that
you see around me
David is traveling to a conference and
he will be broadcasting remotely for the
rest of the week along with Pat and the
full team there a couple stories that I
want to go over here with you while I
fill in for David so over the weekend
Steve Benin I was at the Values Voters
conference the so-called value voters
summit I say that so-called because they
really are a extremely fundamentalist
right wing organization and so it's very
difficult to consider them to be Values
Voters but I digress Steve Bannon was
there and he made a statement with
regard to the CSR payments CSR payment
stands for cost savings reductions which
is a part of the Affordable Care Act
Donald Trump's executive ordered last
week essentially has done away with the
CSR payments and the purpose of doing
this according to Steve Bannon was to
blow up the exchanges we have the video
of that clip and I want to take a listen
to it right now
then you had Obamacare not gonna make
the CSR payments gonna blow that thing
up gonna blow those exchanges up right
now the irony of this is that you have
the audience celebrating and everyone
cheering and applauding but according to
the Associated Press 70 percent of the
people who are going to be hurt by this
are actually voters from states that
Donald Trump won so it's it's it's
another example of the book what's the
matter with Kansas and you have
Republicans audibly celebrating and
cheering on something that is going to
hurt them not only Republicans obviously
when they say 70 percent it's going to
hurt everyone in those states that need
these cost saving reductions and so what
the cost saver reductions essentially
are were payments that the federal
government particularly the executive
branch were making to insurance
companies as a part of the Affordable
Care Act and these reductions were
designed to read
the amount of money poor people are
people who lived that made about 200
percent to two hundred and fifty percent
of the poverty line it gave them the
ability to reduce their not only their
premiums but specifically their co-pays
and their deductibles so over a year
period the silver plan if any of you are
have Obamacare you should be familiar
with their terminology the silver plan
was for people who made about 400% I'm
sorry 200% of the poverty line and the
silver plan with these cost-saving
reductions lowered your annual
deductible from around $3,600 down to
about $200 a year and so now without
these cost saving reductions Steve
Bannon is right this is essentially
going to blow up the exchanges for a
couple of reasons one it's going to
force insurers to increase premiums and
it's going to destabilize the confidence
that these insurers don't really know
how much they need to charge because
they don't know what's going to happen
year after year and so in two very
specific ways it's going to help
destabilize the markets and and the
problem is is that this is something
that they're doing without a replacement
so instead of having something to
replace repeal and replace as Susan
Collins from Maine mentioned you know
one side of the debate was about repeal
and replace and they did not they were
not able to do that because they are
they are completely broken apart they're
scattered they don't really know how to
bring a consensus again together on how
to move forward on healthcare and
there's a very specific ideological
reason why that is but but Susan Collins
pointed out that this step that Donald
Trump made is not about repealing and
replacing it's simply about hurting
Americans we have a clip of her over the
weekend from the State of the Union with
Jake Tapper let's take a listen to that
clip the debate in Washington has been
on whether or not to repeal and replace
Obamacare in the future what the
president is doing is affecting the
ability of vulnerable people to receive
health care
right now this is not a bailout of the
insurance what this money is used for is
to help low-income people afford their
deductibles and their co-pays so that
their healthcare is available to them in
addition the president has taken shift
steps to cut off funding to reach people
who are eligible for subsidies under the
ACA so these certainly are very
disruptive moves that will result in
smaller numbers of people being insured
that will make it more difficult for
low-income people to afford their
out-of-pocket costs and that will
destabilize the insurance markets and so
this is the overall goal of Donald Trump
his goal all along has been to destroy
Obamacare by any means necessary even if
it means hurting people 70% of whom are
in states that voted for Donald Trump
even if it means not having a
replacement anything and everything he
can do to destroy Obamacare not because
he has something better but because he
has a vendetta against President Obama
now Donald Trump actually spoke about
that earlier today and listen to his
tone listen to what he's saying
more specifically listen to the driving
force behind him he is so obsessed with
doing away with Obamacare that he
doesn't care who he hurts in the process
let's take a listen to that clip with
the CSI because I cut off the gravy
train if I didn't cut the CSS they
wouldn't be meeting that'd be having
lunch and enjoying themselves all right
there right now having emergency
meetings to get a short-term fix of
health care where premiums don't have to
double and triple every year like
they've been doing under Obamacare
because Obamacare is finished it's dead
it's gone it's no longer don't you
shouldn't even mention it's God there is
no such thing as Obamacare anymore it is
a and I said this years ago it's a
concept that couldn't have worked and
its best days it couldn't have worked
but we're working on some kind of a
short-term fix prior to the Republicans
getting together maybe with some
Democrat so here he is
he's frustrated because he can't get
Obamacare repealed and so now he's doing
everything he possibly can by
dismantling the program particularly
with these cost-saving reductions and
the entire intent was to blow up the
exchanges this shows you a level of
contempt for or any or lack of concern
for the American people and I and I
think in many ways it seems pointless to
point this out but it's necessary for us
to point this out this move is so
detrimental to the American people it's
almost hysterical because it's not only
targeting the poor people who needed
these cost-saving reductions but it's
also gonna hurt the people who did not
get cost-saving reductions it's also
going to inflate premiums for the
average American the premiums are
considered to are possibly going to go
up about 20% because of this move so
it's not only people who needed Obama
care who gonna be effective every effect
that every single American is going to
be affected if they have insurance of
any type and Donald Trump doesn't care
he Donald Trump doesn't have a solution
Donald Trump doesn't have a better way
forward Donald Trump simply has a
vendetta against President Obama
now this Vendetta actually falls in
lockstep with the overall Republican
ideology now this is the second half of
the conversation right one of the
reasons Donald Trump is so frustrated is
because Republicans can't move forward
and Republicans can't find a way to
repeal and replace Obamacare despite
eight years of making promises that's
because the ideologically do not have a
path forward that is any more
conservative than what Obamacare already
is if they had a solution they would be
able to put it on the table they do not
have a solution and that's because
Obamacare outflanked any of their ideas
from the right Obamacare is a
conservative piece of legislation it
takes market solutions and applies it to
the health care system creating these
exchanges and this is precisely what
Republicans did in Massachusetts with
Mitt Romney this is exactly what the
Heritage Foundation promoted previously
and because Obama did it they are more
obsessed with undoing Obama's legacy
than they are with it
admitting that the plan that we
currently have as flawed as it is is
actually a plan that they would have
implemented had Obama not done at first
and because they don't have any
ideological way of going any further to
the right without absolutely destroying
Americans they can't find a solution
whatsoever and this is a particularly
hysterical quagmire that they have
themselves in because they want to do
something but they have nowhere else to
go except for kill as many Americans as
they possibly can because they will put
and this is not hyperbole right let me
let me take a step back people get upset
when we talk in inflammatory sentences
like this but there's a study that
revealed that there's ten to forty
thousand people a year that would die as
a result of lack of coverage because of
any type of repeal of Obamacare even
with this one move of of Donald Trump
doing away with the CSR payments Donald
Trump is getting ready to knock off 1
million Americans this single move is
going to cause 1 million Americans to no
longer have access to affordable health
care and this is what the Republicans
are faced with because they don't have
any way to outflank it so ideally you
would think well what's a better
solution and the Republicans will say ok
let's get a better solution but that's
wishful thinking because the better
solution is really Medicare for all
Medicare for all is the wait board
because we have a system and this is
particularly important Donald Trump
right now is able to undermine the
Affordable Care Act with the stroke of a
pen because he has that capacity is the
President of the United States even
without Congress Congress could
undermine the Affordable Care Act every
single year if they had authorized these
CSR payments but they didn't so
President Obama back in 2014
took it into his own hands and used the
executive branch to authorize these
payments from the Treasury
well this presupposes that you are going
to always have somebody in power that is
actually a decent human being right
Obamacare required
that you either have a House of
Representatives and a Senate and a
president for that matter to sign off on
the budget but to at least have a House
of Representatives that were willing to
sign off on these CSR payments annually
as a part of their budget and we haven't
had that since the Democrat Republicans
took over in 2010 I believe 2010 was the
year that the Republicans got the
majority in the house
so Obamacare required and necessitated
to have decent people who cared about
health care for all in the House of
Representatives or at a minimum in the
White House and without having somebody
decent in the White House we now see
that Obamacare is uniquely vulnerable
because we have a president who has the
ability to sign away a system that is
going to fundamentally destabilize Obama
care all right so there's a lot more to
cover on this issue and we'll definitely
keep our eyes on it but I think it's
very important for us to see these these
fundamental flaws in Obamacare not as a
way of criticizing what President Obama
did or what Nancy Pelosi did or what all
the other people who did they put a lot
of time into building it but now we see
it's very exposed how detrimental or how
vulnerable rather this program is to the
whims of a narcissistic president and
because of that I think it's vitally
important that we begin to advocate for
the same thing that Kamala Harris is
advocating for the same thing that
Elizabeth Warren is now advocating for
the same thing Cory Booker I mean even
Cory Booker is advocating for and of
course senator Bernie Sanders they are
all advocating for Medicare for all
because we cannot afford to have a
system that is dependent on the
benevolence of the people in power we
need assist them that is steady and
stable and doesn't change with the
changing administration we'll be back
right after this